alors radio canada international salue
la planète sur notre nouvelle caméra de
profil
cette fin vous êtes ici un studio vous
avez fait des sacrifices au sein de
l'équipe pour vous présenter vous avait
autre chose à faire mais l'essentiel
c'est vous soyez ici de voter ces
bénévoles à ya pas de rapports alors
alléchante à de chandelle est avec nous
bonjour à l'iss
je demande marie claude simard est à ce
jour quel beau nom de famille
les régimes inouïe la gagne on rappelle
le règlement ces deux là sont les web
ainsi contrôler tout ils peuvent pas
ouvrir fermer des micros mais peuvent
ouvrir et fermer l'image du côté du son
il ya pierre aux techniciens de radio
canada qui est de l'autre côté de la
vitre et bonjour pierre et puis il ya
tous finalement toute la planète et à
des coûts
vous connaissez vous savez comment
commencer l'émission pour devenir le
sujet de l'aide de l'émission oui oui
oui les images cinq images cinq images
de la vidéo 5 images top on présente
pense que paloma vous avez une idée du
sujet donc vous ne pourrez pas parlé non
vous étiez assis à côté de moi cette
semaine alice oui et puis aussi des cinq
images dites moi quel est le sujet de
l'émission cette semaine leonardo oui en
bonne partie mais plus encore l'image du
martroi les roues mais brutalité
policière
mon dieu vous n'aviez pas droit les
palomas oui vous avez c'est ça je vais
vous avez comment dire c'est une réflexe
professionnel vous avez la réponse vous
seriez vous soyez tous les débats et
wright comme cette assise à côté de moi
vous devenu sujet de la semaine
au fil des entrevues et téléphone que
l'on l'âge alors voilà ces sujets zéro
de conduite quand nos policiers ne sont
plus nos héros parce que j tiennent les
policiers c'est nos héros mal d'arrivées
c'est des gens qui nous sauve de pas mal
de situations mais si en fin de compte
ils deviennent plutôt des bourgs
pour nous ça devient problématique mais
quel beau jeu de mot fantastique
alors évidemment cela riez tic dérivés
de l'est moins je vais avant que l'on a
est dans le vif du sujet pas être trop
sanguin allons-y avec le jeu de la
grosse boule première manche
éclairage maestro on tamise alors vous
connaissez le règlement trois jeux par
émission de la grosse boule fait trois
jeux de la grosse boule par édition
n'ajoutons pas alors le premier je vous
prends 20 points
je sais que chantal ça vous est tendu
parce que vous avez déjà ce genre de
situation mais bon allons-y on va voir
alors le but ici c'est de connaître le
monde des policiers au canada de bien
décrire aux auditeurs à l'étranger de
bien sûr informer les canadiens qui ne
connaîtraient rien sur cette cette
affaire alors voici la question combien
y at-il de policiers au canada en
partance de 1000 habitants
combien y at-il de policiers au canada
par tranche de 1000 habitants
la tranche de 1000 néonataux
[Musique]
81 80 par 1000 habitants
moi je dirais 5 5,5 par mille d'accord
cinquante six fois plus
donc vous êtes plus pour l'ordre - et
puis palma ça ça alors vous allez me
dire qui est le plus proche de la bonne
réponse le 15 mai 2016 il y avait
soixante mille sept cent soixante treize
policiers au canada ce qui se traduit
par un taux de 5 90 policiers pour mille
ou cent d'accord oui
donc ça veut dire 1,9 par 1000 habitants
à 90 pour cent mille habitants mille
habitants emile canât bloquer l'action
est bon donc fi section vous avez 20
points 12 accordé cinq points
parce que on a cru que vous aviez alors
050 c'est bien encadré par des héros pas
de problème alors je voulais on va
porter les choses plus sérieuses
maintenant je vous présentais un
quinzaine de la violence policière ou en
cas d'égarement d'accord alors c'est de
te dis oui une vidéo numéro 2 ça s'est
passé en 2014 à montréal alors sa sortie
du métro
un policier qui ne n'ont pas deux
pareils ça c'est bon on peut regarder
deux sas élit le nombre de policiers par
tranche de cinq mille habitants dans le
monde et aux états unis est un peu plus
élevé je pense que c'est marqué 248 le
mexique votre pays où vous êtes n'est
pas le mans oui c'est comme en france
très élevé on parle ici de temps que je
regarde les chiffres on omet de mon but
c'était de vie 356 en france 350 au
mexique avec la situation sociale en
france est très tendue effectifs
argentine russie des autres
les plus élevés au monde voilà ça
c'était pour ajouter un peu
d'informations qui nous intéresse c'est
ça le son est pas très bon
un simple passant à la sortie du métro
film c'est un sens après une personne
sans abri
le policier le menace d'un coup tu
dégages
sinon je vais d'enchaîner un poteau il
fait moins 20 degrés celsius vivant
[Musique]
c'est toujours ça a basculé
on est en train de faire non mais
franchement le supplice serait vraiment
de la tâche est cette personne
un poteau une personne qui n'a pas de
manteau et nous sommes en plein hiver
c'est dire le caractère vraiment
inhumain de la situation alors vous avez
choix ici est ce que vous allez servir
un avertissement ce policier une
réprimande le blâmer le suspendre sans
salaire pour une période d'au plus 60
jours ouvrables le rétrograder ou le
destituer qu'est-ce que vous tient là
prévient ce mois je le recommanderais
parce qu'en réalité il ne pas attacher
sur le bouton n'a pas attaché
j'ai déjà vu des ces gens de choses dans
les métros il y avait un sable y aussi
puis avec quatre policiers qui
l'entouraient pied
toi mon pote la façon dont ils
communiquent avec les ans à paris
c'était pas aussi respectueuse je
comprends la personne les ensembles ils
n'étaient pas non plus très très polis
mais quand même il faudrait qu'elle
montre avec l'ex ans exactement les
polices les policiers c'est l'exemple
c'est nos héros nourrir ou non pas pour
faire un peu l'avocat du diable je
dirais quand même qu'on les voit aussi
souvent justement dans le métro avec des
gens de la rue puis enlevez moi je les
trouve très patient je les trouve
ça n'est pas parfait non non elle soit
patient étant donné que d'habitude c'est
des gens à un teint qui ont des
problématiques de santé mentale très
souvent donc c'est des personnes
vulnérables qui doit traiter avec d'une
certaine manière quoi moi je comprends
aussi les points de vue des maris club
parce que ces gens là c'est pas un fois
c'est un 30/1 des fois dans le métro
c'est la même passion qui fait la même
chose
et alors les policiers dont je pense que
dans un moment donné deux doivent être
tanné de la même situation puis parce
que c'est leur travail
il est là moi par exemple ce que je
trouve que c'est pas très bon du parti
de la pole ici de la police c'est quand
on conduit eux ils font des taux ils
font des manoeuvres qu'il faut pas faire
quand on quand on conduit dans la rue
puis
c'est la police il sait pas mais c'est
un autre citoyen si ça vaut un bon il
faut mettre les lumières c'est vrai nom
mais pour revenir à notre sujet donc les
policiers face à des personnes
vulnérables dans des stations de métro
je trouve que en même temps il faut pas
abuser il faut pas utiliser de moyens
disproportionnés contre ces personnes là
qui des fois son ensemble
dans ce cas ci le patron du policier dit
on va je vais lui parler monado mail du
genre une petite conversation avec lui
bon mais je pense que ça n'a pas été
beaucoup plus loin mais je pense que
c'est juste un quart que l'on voit
quelqu'un qui vulnérables on sent que
bien qu'il ya eu de la pression légitime
sur lui on sent tous un peu vulnérable
par rapport au politique et un peu quel
la puissance dans les bras je me
rappelle quand j'ai fait les cours de
français s'est fait l'écho france est il
venu policiers nous dire que bah oui on
sait qu'ils vont dans vos pays là pour
la pole ici il fait des abus ici c'est
pas la même chose mais mais je vise je
dit excusez moi monsieur vous avez une
arme
moi non il ya déjà une différence très
très très grave
de là vous parlez de l'argentine qui
n'ont très très élevé de ces deux
policiers mais la police et la police
argentine
ah voilà donc les cas d'écart option
c'est vraiment élevé ici aussi il ya de
la corruption parmi les policiers il ya
même une unité dans kate qui a été formé
alors c'est on parlera pas des cas
criminels disons où il ya eu mort bon on
va aller vers quelqu'un qui s'occupe
dont c'est le travail d'essayer de gérer
les conflits entre les citoyens et les
corps policiers lorsqu'une plainte qui
est logée contre un policier et je
repartais parler d'un cas très précis
qui t'arrive est un des membres de nos
de nos équipes de notre équipe
aujourd'hui pas aujourd'hui mais
récemment mais on va faire aujourd'hui
alors voici le commissaire à la
déontologie policière marc andré dowd du
québec et avec ou d'ordre
bonjour à toute l'équipe sympathique ce
monsieur et il a accepté de nous de nous
expliquer comment ça fonctionne la
prochaine fois qu'on va aller se
plaindre
et je vous dis que moi je vous dis ça
car des frissons parce que j'ai moi
l'idée me viendrait pas d'aller me
plaindre la dernière chose que
j'essayerai de faire parce que je sais
qu'il ya une relation pouvoir même une
fois que l'acte a été accompli ou la
présumée est injuste a été accompli il
ya d'après moi un appareil administratif
incroyable auquel je vais devoir faire
face et j'ai l'impression que j'aurais à
le faire face seul devant tout ça ça je
vous donne mes impressions très biaisée
aucun renseignement sur la réalité dit
pas comment ça se passe en réalité
alors comment ça se passe la première
chose vous avez raison de dire que les
policiers font un travail important
nécessaire mais dans les conditions
souvent difficiles et faut savoir qu'un
code de déontologie qui s'applique à
tous les policiers du québec équipe skis
des normes de conduite des devoirs que
les policiers doivent respecter par
exemple toujours respecté être poli avec
les citoyens ne pas abuser de la force
vont parler de larmes par exemple n'est
pas utile utilisé son arme avec prudence
uniquement dans les situations c'est
nécessaire et cetera et lorsqu'il ya un
manquement et bien il ya en fait deux
organismes le commissaire le bureau du
comme salle quelques jeux président qui
est un organisme administratif donc nous
on reçoit les plaintes ont fait un
premier tri des plaintes on parle
environs de 1800 à 1900 2000 plaintes
par année qu'on reçoit beaucoup et sur
ce nombre là donc une première analyse
qui est fait
il ya un certain nombre de plaintes qui
rentrent plus loin parce que on ne pense
qu'il faut pour aller plus loin et pour
je dirais un bon montant d'aidé planète
environ 30 % des plaintes reçues
on va offrir ce qu'on appelle la
conciliation et ça on n'en a pas parlé
depuis le début de l'émission je veux
insister là dessus c'est pour les
allégations moins graves les allégations
par exemple d'impolitesse que le citoyen
s'est pas sentie respecter chez terra
lorsqu'on va faire c'est que dans un
endroit neutre
le bureau du commissaire en présence
d'un conciliateur ou d'une conciliatrice
de mon bureau le citoyen va rencontrer
le policier qui sera pas en uniforme qui
sera pas armé à cette occasion aulas
pourrait changer
revenir sur les événements et on se rend
compte que c'est très apprécié des
citoyens cette possibilité-là de revenir
sur les événements de pouvoir parler aux
policiers de changer avec lui est
généralement l'un des taux de règlement
qui sont à peu près de 85% la suite de
cette rencontre
donc le citoyen dit mais j'ai eu
l'occasion d'échanger
je comprends mieux maintenant je suis
satisfait pour à peu près 10% des cas ce
sera les allégations les plus graves
on va aller en enquête et là il ya un
enquêteur qui va vraiment faire toute la
lumière sur la situation et au terme de
cette enquête là je vais avoir une
décision ensemble si j'ai une preuve
qu'un manquement grave qui était comique
j'estime que j'ai suffisamment preuve je
vais pouvoir à ce moment là cités c'est
ce qu'on appelle dans la loi ces sites
et le policier devant un tribunal
spécialisé qui s'appelle le comité de
déontologie policière
et là il ya un petit procès j'ai un
petit merci c'est vraiment une audition
d'un avocat une avocate de mon bureau
représente le commissaire représenter
les témoins va présenter la preuve
contre le policier qui lui aussi
représenté par avocat va faire valoir sa
défense et le comité va décider est-ce
qu manquement au code de déontologie et
6 rue manquement le comité a aussi
imposé une sanction
j'ai pas besoin de nommer les sanctions
avaient très bien fait tout à l'heure et
donc c'est un peu comme ce que le
système fonctionne bah écoutez ça c'est
pour le le citoyen parlé d'un taux de
satisfaction 85 % lorsqu'il ya cette
rencontre de conciliation qui est
l'outil principal pour générique conflit
a par an maintenant
le policier lui est ce que ces 85 % de
satisfaction ce qu'ils aiment sens
présentée en conciliation
je mentirais si je disais que c'était
une bonne nouvelle pour un policier de
recevoir un courrier de mon bureau là ça
veut dire qu'un problème dans un dossier
mais cela dit la loi ne lui laisse pas
le choix le policier a l'obligation de
se présenter en considération lorsqu'il
conciliation décrétée alors ils
connaissent bien le système sa com
comment ça fonctionne et est en fait si
si ça se passe pas bien qu'on situation
si le policier est fermé on a dû tout
fermer les citoyens veut tout simplement
dire moi je ne veux pas réglé mon
dossier et je laisse aux commissaires le
soin de décider de la suite
est-ce qu'il va y avoir enquête ou non
mais là ce moment-là ça revient sur mon
bureau mais c'est tout à l'avantagé du
policier d'essayer d'être ouvert de
revenir avec les citoyens et à la
satisfaction de ce dernier parce qu'à ce
moment le dossier s'arrête là nico pas
le risque qui a une autre étape qui soit
l' enquête où le comité de déontologie
cela dit je veux juste faire un élément
je pense est important de dire dans les
codes allégations graves par exemple
aurait eu des blessures ou deux j'ai un
dossier plus ça me paraît très graves
comme situation je n'ai pas l'obligation
d'offrir la conciliation je peux dire
j'ai un pouvoir discrétionnaire pour
dire non ça j'en vois ça tout de suite
on enquête c'est trop grave
donc il y aura pas de conciliation dans
ce dossier marie-claude oui alors moi
j'aimerais concernant justement le
processus de conciliation dans mon
entourage et quelqu'un justement que
participer à une rencontre de
continuation quelqu'un qui m'est très
proche quelqu'un qui a subi des
blessures physiques avec dans une
altercation avec la police
j'étais même pas au courant que ça
existait depuis mon premier réflexe a
été de me dire je trouve ça bien parce
que chacun peut finir ses phrases si tu
peux aller au bout de sa démarche je
peux vraiment de vider le cas tu peux
parler à la personne dans les yeux de
comment tu t'es senti qu est ce que tu
as vécu je me demande par contre de
quelle façon le public est vraiment bien
servi par ces pros ce processus parce
que en bout de ligne
de quelle façon est ce que la
déontologie va être encore mieux
respectés va être encore il va vraiment
avoir une amélioration parce qu'en fait
c'est ça qu'on veut c'est que qu'est ce
que vous en pensez
en fait l'objectif de la déontologie
c'est de prévenir un objectif de
prévention prévenir la récurrence de
situations comme ça alors oui un
objectif de punir certaines situations
dans certains comme aimait le régime et
surtout pensés pour conscientiser les
policiers pour les interventions futures
alors en ce sens là quand ça se passe
bien conciliation moins optimiste de
nature je fais confiance à la je pense
que l'être humain est bon dans la
majorité des grandes majorité des
situations donc
confiance à ce côté là pour que le
policier train de conscience de ce qui
s'est passé ici donne comme une
opportunité je dirais de réfléchir de
façon critique sur sa pratique sur la
façon dont les exerce son métier
un prix est ce qui se passe et si on
leur voix en conciliation deux ou trois
fois campus dire les dix ans qui apprend
pas et là je peux décider dire mais la
prochaine fois il s'en vend une enquête
alors sauf si c'est possible donc le
régime est quand même assez souple pour
ça vous parliez tantôt 2800 plaintes
enregistrées chaque année
et j'aimerais bien savoir quels sont les
allégations qui reviennent le plus
souvent dans ces plaintes là autrement
quels sont les comportements le plus
souvent dénoncé chez les policiers de la
part des citoyens qui se plaignent
ouais alors c'est une excellente
question lieu une première partie
j'espère que nos auditeurs vont retenir
ça il ya quand même
et s'il est là vont pas très loin il ya
plusieurs personnes qui déposent une
plainte pour contester un constat
d'infraction par exemple le policier m'a
donné un constat parce que j'ai passé
mon stop c'est pas vrai j'ai fait mon
stop et long play on n'est pas la bonne
place là il faut aller en cour
municipale il faut contester constats
d'infraction donc soit on a un certain
nombre de plaintes qui arrête tout de
suite à l'étape initiale
les plaintes les plus nombreuses elles
sont relatives je dirais à de
l'impolitesse des propos injurieux
policiers qui auraient sacré par exemple
des propos discriminatoires dans
certains cas fondés sur la race
l'orientation sexuelle par exemple dans
plusieurs situations d des allégations
des luttes force physique
alors c'est compliqué ces dossiers là
parce que ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
les policiers ont le droit d'utiliser la
force nécessaire dans l'exercice de
leurs fonctions si un policier mais en
état d'arrestation quelqu'un et que la
personne résiste
légalement le policier ont le droit
d'utiliser la force qui est nécessaire
pour se faire écouter sans talent auquel
que le citoyen tempère mais pas une
force qui soit excessif alors ça ces
dossiers là on enquête ça va être
souvent de dire qu'elle est de lire et
de force qui étudie par exemple si la
personne est déjà maîtrisé au les
menottes et que les policiers portent le
coup après ce coup là il n'y a pas à
première vue il s'explique pas
la personne maîtriser ya pas il ya pas
lieu de la frapper et puis par la suite
on va étudier les policiers y ont des
techniques d'intervention fils et qui
ils sont formés à l'école pour
intervenir physiquement on va voir dans
une intervention est ce que ça s'est
déroulé comme on l'enseigné à l'école
alors ça c'est un très bon type de
plainte qu'on reçoit jeudi est ce que
vous êtes obligés dé foi de renvoyer le
policier à l'école ste afre affaires de
faire ce qu'il faut lire la loi prévoit
que j'ai un pouvoir de recommandation et
que dans ce poids de recommandation le
jeu peut recommander de la formation en
toute honnêteté je vais vous dire que
moi ça fait un an que je suis en poste
je n'ai pas fait encore mais avec votre
question ça me rappelle que c'est une
possibilité que j'ai dans la loi oui
vous mentionnez pas leur demander des
plaintes concernant des cas de
discrimination qui aurait été dénoncé
par des citoyens vous savez les idées
les valeurs les 58 sion les points de
vue sont pas visibles donc on peut pas
savoir quand on engage un policier tous
et c'est pâques et des choses qui
viennent avec cette personne là comment
on peut évaluer ça comment on peut
évaluer que notre policier est vraiment
neutre qui est vraiment que c'est si dès
que ces valeurs correspondent à une
mission neutre et objective de ddrrr de
la société je pense que c'est très
difficile présenté comme que vous l'avez
présenter ce qu'on peut s'attendre c'est
que par ses actions ce qu'il a dans la
tête on n'a pas accès mais que par ses
actions par ces propos et il ne démontre
aucune discrimination donc il ne
démontre aucun traitement défavorable
envers une personne en raison de son
appartenance par exemple un groupe
ethnique en raison d'un handicap et
caetera et dans plusieurs dossiers on a
des allégations à l'effet qu'ils
auraient eu de la discrimination
je vais être honnête avec vous dans
plusieurs dossiers c'est difficile à
prouver ces allégations aussi à moins
qu'on ait des propos précis mais choix
ça va rester de l'ordre de la perception
de l'intuition du sang
si mais quand vient le temps de dire ce
que j'ai à ses preuves je suis je dit
non j'ai pas cette preuve nécessairement
très bien alors oui question est ce
qu'on peut filmer quand on voit quelque
chose comme ça cette question là alors
le droit est clair là dessus on a le
droit de bail damas pas si vous êtes au
volant
[Rires]
mais un témoin a le droit de filmer une
intervention policière dans la mesure où
ils n'entravent pas le travail d'un
policier alors vous avez droit de filmer
mais si vous approcher trop près que le
policier vous du recul et je travaille
vous devez écouter le policier vous
devez vous avez reculé dante oui au
droit de filmer sans entraver le travail
que peu de sens que parce que la
situation que j'ai racontée dans les
métros j'ai failli sorcier mon
cellulaire puis l'a pas dit une des
policiers m'a dit nono vous pouvez pas
face à jeudi ok je suis la police me dis
que je peux pas face à je vais pas faire
ça mais maintenant je ne ratant que mes
questions et y amener à quelques
reprises devant le comité de déontologie
policière puis le droit est clair là
dessus
qu'est-ce qu'est ce qu'on dit aux
policiers pour pas se faire coincer va
prolonger droit de filmer et tu
n'entends pas loin de la commissaire
nous l'a dit qu'est ce que les écouter
c'est très sympathique tout ça moi je
suis prêt à déposer ma planète
est-ce que j'ai besoin d'un avocat non
absolument pas mais j'ai rien quand les
avocats j'en suis moi même mais
l'objectif étant qu'elles
le système soit le plus simple le plus
ouvert le plus accessible pour les
citoyens alors par exemple en
conciliation vous avez le droit de vous
faire accompagner d'une personne de
votre choix pour assister la
conciliation
ça peut être un avocat mais ça peut être
aussi un ami un voisin un conjoint qui
est le pauvre pour vous aider dans la
situation aussi donc non absolument pas
besoin d'avoir un avocat
et si on va à l'étape suivante et que au
bout du compte je décide de citer le
policier mais c'est un de mes avocats
qui va présenter la preuve donc à ce
moment là c'est des avocats de mon
bureau qui qui qui gère le dossier
judiciaire toutes satisfaites
oui c'est ça va ça va je pose la
question parce que quelqu'un dans sa
famille qui a passé à travers le
processus s'était pas entière
satisfaction je pense au bout de la
digue
mais je crois que ça allait c'est ce
qu'avait des frais qu'elle était
encourue les blessures bien évidemment
l'argent il ya report jamais de
compensation financière
on s'entend là-dessus parce que
plusieurs personnes le demande
notre bureau n'a pas le pouvoir de
demander une compensation financière
alors il faut prendre ce moment leur
recours civil et la wii est probablement
avec un avocat fait sciemment
mais moi dans ma loi je n'ai pas le
pouvoir de demander des dédommagements
monétaire pour les dommages subis par
exemple vous êtes avocat est ce que vous
êtes aussi policiers n'ont absolument
pas d'ailleurs c'est bien reposé la
question
nous sommes un organisme civil de
surveillance des policiers parce que je
voyais dans tous les sites web ont dit à
la police qui enquête sur la police le
système au québec c'est un système de
surveillance civile des activités
policiers avaient existé policière assez
important donc le commissaire la
commissaire adjointe ce ne sont pas des
anciens policiers
j'ai des anciens policiers dans non plus
que les conspirateurs conciliatrice j'ai
des anciens policiers qui agissaient
comme enquêteur
mais ils ne sont plus policier et j'y
vois deux grands avantages parce qu'ils
connaissent le travail policiers l'ayant
déjà fait mais la décision elle est
prise par des civils
parce que font un rapport d'enquêté la
décision elle est prise par décider
d'une réponse et mini que gestion aimez
vous votre travail
l'air d'aimer mon travail m'a fait un
tout nouvel environnement moi je viens
de la commission des droits de la
personne et du protecteur du citoyen
donc c'est la suite dans la défense des
droits pour moi j'adore mon travail puis
une mini mini question est ce que votre
bureau c'est pour tout les policiers du
québec c'est à dire la sûreté du québec
puis la police est montréal puis la
police de laval aussi alors c'est tous
les policiers du québec incluant les
policiers autochtones une exception on
ne traite pas les plaines qui vise la
grc pour des raisons constitutionnelles
c'est la police fédérale
mais là dessus on prend aussi les
plaines concernant les constables
spéciaux dans les palais de justice les
contrôleurs routiers les agents de
protection de la faune les agents de
l'upac et maintenant du bureau des
enquêtes indépendantes
vous êtes nommé par le bureau du premier
ministre du québec c'est ça ou le permis
c est comment les policiers eux mêmes
perçoivent le travail que vous faites
il faudrait leur demander si on a des
contacts réguliers avec les
représentants des policiers
je sens de ces courtoise sens du respect
l'important c'est qu'on est un canal de
communication mais c'est sûr que on
demeurera toujours le chien de garde de
leurs actions donc c'est ça c'est fini
les questions on va perdre le lien avec
le satellite
le décompte est lancé
écoutez merci beaucoup nous avoir parlé
de façon aux simples volontaires d'avoir
rendu humain un sujet de préoccupation
je pense pour tous les citoyens ont fait
tout ce qui était à l'écouté puis sur
beaucoup de gens ici autour de la table
alors monsieur marc-andré daoud
commissaire à la déontologie policière
vous êtes encore quatre autres années si
j'ai bien compris mandat de cinq ans
merci à vous c'était très agréable bien
sûr à bientôt
je veux retrouver mon comité de nom mais
très sérieusement certains vraiment là
on a appris des choses qui sont tous en
confiance que je voulais savoir
dans la dernière question c'est si la
plupart des plaintes sont pour une telle
spécifique des polices c'est à dire
c'est la police de montréal du québec
en fait la plupart des plaintes ces
concernant le matricule 727 dit oui
sinon je voulais pas dire adieu aux
dangers menacent de poursuites ici
oui on peut pas kelly non 727 existe
peut-être donc matricule 268 1728 vous
avez une bonne mémoire
mais imaginez ce qui se trouve à
l'extérieur du québec même dans le monde
ne savent pas qui était la matricule 728
c'était une dame fils officier de police
vous voulez on va avant de lui de lui
palu parti qu'on lui parle et on va voir
ce qu'elle a fait non on va attendre
matin c'est le mystère on va ensuite
passer deux publicités ensuite on ira
vers la vidéo faire un peu d'argent la
prétention alors écoutez voici c'est
notre deuxième jeu les lumières s'il
vous plaît le jeu de la boule tacos bull
2e manche
chantal tout de suite elle se voit si le
15 mai 2016 se fait pas tellement
longtemps sa fête de printemps les
femmes représentaient quel pourcentage
de tous les policiers harcèlement
assermentés au canada quel pourcentage
de tous les policiers sont étaient des
femmes en 2016 le ans au mois de mai de
bon sens 2% très bien 10 % 10 % vais
pour sa 20 pour cent soixante pour sa
veine 2% pour vous rapporter chaque
intrants points parce que vous avez
pratiquement la bonne réponse et 21%
alors le score de 0 21%
10 c'est sans vous avez donné dix plus
ce 30 ça fait cinquante plus ce 30 ça
fait cinquante sa valeur 06 50
maintenant mais pourquoi est ce que vous
vous avez rien dire parce que je suis
honnête c'est vrai c'est la preuve qu'il
y ait fait un bon policier voit si on
n'y prête pour la vidéo on va oublier
les publicités alors voici celle à m à
l'époque 728 c'était ok manille x2014
alors poivre de cayenne
parmi les manifestants c'est ça qui a
fait exploser à faire usage proportionné
de la force et la légation parce que au
bout de la ligne je pense que ya pas eu
de on a dit que c'était justifié dans
l'ensemble c'était pas la première fois
où elle a fait parler d'elle mais ça
c'était la première fois
je pars hier parce que ensuite ce
qu'elle a fait ça c'est triste ça se
poursuit comme ça pendant trois minutes
et puis un jeune qu'il acquit à rendre
la policière lui disant tu es fier de
toi
madame ses dépenses à youtube ce soir et
puis aussi ce soir salle est passé à
youtube
c'est une star elle est restée calme
carton du film il faut faire attention à
ça c'était des manifestants qui
manifestaient c'est facile à dire mais
telles qu'on les voilà qui voyez mais
vous voulez vous qu'elle vous décris
vraiment quelle était la situation pour
ça si l'image captée par retransmis sur
les médias voici ce qu'elle avait à dire
ça c'était à l'émission qui est un peu
copié notre formule qui s'appelle tout
le monde en parle à radio canada que
c'est
plusieurs invités un seul ou deux
animateurs nous c'est un plusieurs
animateurs nationalité voici très belle
entrevue j'ai un extrait agents 275
rebaptisé renommée voilà ça n'existe pas
mais je le son le son la police si tu ne
fais pas y voir des conséquences
ces gens là ont refusé systématiquement
de s'en aller non seulement il refuse de
s'en aller mais il forcer la ligne
physiquement nous rentrer dedans
asseyez d'attaquer les chevaux donc moi
aussi c'est vous qui allez au fond
pourquoi les autres bougent pas parce
que moi sur cette ligne ces mots la plus
vieille se moque était la mieux équipée
c'est également moi qui étais un âge
enseignants alors c'est moi qui est
équipé du support des clients qui
servait à la dispersion
je joue qu'un avis way où c'est la seule
à la roche est la seule à avoir la
formation aussi pour l'utiliser puis
combien de temps ce format sur une
journée on s'est lancé toutes sortes de
choses que je peux même pas imaginer
c'est si je vous dis qu'il ya des gens
qui étaient là spécifiquement pour
lancer de lasso beaucoup parce que le
coup était dégagé c'est une des choses
que les gens sachent profit c'est pas
quand on est dans le milieu dans les
mains comme ce sport jo non
je comprends qu'il ya certainement des
agitateurs dans des manifestations
autant de monde oui en effet c'est
malheureux parce que ça a duré 45
minutes
on voit seulement 30 secondes mais tout
les médias et l e ils ont pas filmer
toutes les 45 minutes ils ont pas mal
dans le contexte qui trente secondes qui
existe une bavure
évidemment ça vous a mis sur la mappe
tenons au québec vous connaissez c'est
comme ça et ça lui appartement continuum
de force que nous exploitons 10 me j'ai
toujours milité son jeu pour raconter 29
parce que ça vous met à des bons côtés
justement à je comprends que ça peut
être sympa et intéressant d'avoir un
téléphone d'en face oui mais il ya des
bons côtés justement est ce que tu
penses ou excuse moi je t'ai je te
tutoyer solide recours certaines bavures
aussi tout le monde nous regarde tout le
temps au débat
regardez on mange on se regarde et on
intervient au se faire regarder aussi
constamment regarder et jamais au
centre-ville que tu peux intervenez puis
à pau personnes alentours de toi donc
c'est consciemment que tu sais que tu
vas te fumer mais ok mais si tu es
capable d'exécuter intervention
qu'est-ce que mal
moi j'ai été blanchi pour le poivre de
cayenne sont le pot mentionné on a fait
des gros sacs ice a pris 18 mois encore
10 écoute à la fête sa job mais aux yeux
de tous mangé pato de gbagbo alors
stéphanie trudeau alliance matricule 728
ne fait plus partie maintenant de la
police et puis il ya une récente
décision de rendre justement par le
comité de déontologie policière du
québec a déclaré qu' elle avait manqué
de respect de politesse un dans une
autre histoire
et puis ne s'était pas préoccupé de la
sécurité du détenu qui se trouvait dans
son véhicule de patrouille
une autre histoire qu'on racontera pas
les détails sinon allez à la noël mais
et sa liste est longue de le faire les
gens sont souvent finalement elle était
quoi tu m'as bleus il ya des
problématiques
oui oui oui bah c'est ça il ya de ces
secondes a déclaré un moment donné
moi je pense que j'aime beaucoup dans
cette entrevue c'est qu'on découvre
quelqu'un
derrière le scandale l'image l'effet
médiatique moi j'ai découvert quelqu'un
puis j'aurai mince et vous présenter 15
minutes parce qu'on découvre quelqu'un
vous l'avez vu aussi aussi sa mort je
les trouvais comme je suis devenu j'aime
vraiment mieux compris son métier c'est
ce qu'elle avait à faire puis surtout
j'ai compris l'espèce d'engouement
médiatique qui nous fait vraiment juste
voir un côté l'histoire qui nous remet à
répétition toujours les mêmes missions
c'est une histoire de famille son amour
pour le pour les activités policières si
je comprends bien mais son père était
policier puis elle a suivi ses traces
c'est quelqu'un qui est très sensible
malgré son sens aux allures costaud je
crois que son allure a pas été
malheureusement les gens en sourdine on
peut peut-être jouer beaucoup sur son
expulsion de peut-être que c'est une
forme de préjugé finalement médiatique
lui par appareil et justement je pense
que cette femme pose un problème sérieux
en ce qui concerne le traitement de
l'information
le choix des images et parle de 45
secondes des images sorties d'un lot
donc là dedans que c'était quoi les
images qu'il fallait véritablement
montré est ce que les journalistes ont
toujours le temps qu'il faut ou faire le
tour de la question et montrez vraiment
l'authentic les images qu'il fallait
vraiment montrer ses les lenteurs de la
manifestation c'était très lent c'était
pas comme s'il y avait une crise
inquiète en train cela fait donc aucune
urgence y avait pas d'urgence
il y avait un mouvement répétées de la
part des manifestants qui en arrive est
toujours au même point
il faut ici qui va les repousser
toujours au même point c'était une
histoire qui traînait comme ça dans cela
vient un peu souvent questionné les
choix des rédactions perçu finalement on
comprend que les journalistes ont montré
qu'ils veulent bien montrer et 80
un choix d on essaie de montrer la
plupart des choses mais vraiment c'est
sûr on découpe la réalité pour montrer
ce fait moi je pense qu'en réalité on
l'avait pas justement sur film tout
l'événement on a décidé de prendre du
matériel citoyens s'étaient pas du
matériel journalistique qu'on aurait
joué à 12e en guinée mais en réalité si
ça va être un caméraman de me dire le
mans qui s'était dit moi je vois
vraiment présenter un événement comme il
s'est présenté ça aurait peut-être qu'on
aurait vraiment changé dans les médias
maintenant depuis quelques années qu'on
voit pas ce que c'est
c'est viral on voit là ben on se sent
comme obligé de présenter des images
parce que c'est pas nous qui présente ça
va être un autre média de fait alors
rage entre les jonctions on a
l'impression que les journalistes
quelque part on voulu accabler la
policière en ne montrant que cet aspect
les réalités on n'avait probablement pas
d'image du reste mais je pense que c'est
constant s'excuse qu'est ce qu'il faut
faire quand on n'a pas toujours les bons
réglages pour des mots étayer ce qu'on
veut faire percevoir au public qu'est ce
qu'il faut faire si on lui a donné
parole à radio canada il est venu à tout
le monde les dégâts sont faits est finie
ouais ouais déjà fait plus partie
pendant corps policier année sera encore
peut-être
mais elle avait quand même un
comportement brusque à noter dans les
autres cas où il allait au loin
sa présence la perception que le public
peut avoir d'une telle personne
c'est le phénomène de l'utilisation de
la force comme en parler notre invité
jusqu'où doit aller on peut aller parce
qu'elle va mesures qui n'étaient pas
bien réglée j'ai fait je connais un
passage une amie qui est qui travaille
dans la police et la police de laval
puis lui mais raconter qui passe 24
heures de service alors il ya plusieurs
événements dans la journée qui qui qui
lui doit gd puis parfois les derniers
c'est un événement avec beaucoup de
pression
puis 7-7 une être humain quand même 24
fois oui je sais pas exactement si c'est
toujours comme ça c'était une caisse
spéciale mais lui il m'a dit ces jours
un jour qui j'ai frappé quelqu'un c'est
j'ai commencé on appelle à huit heures
du matin on a eu à on est allé sortir en
pensant que c'est pas dessus parler avec
les familiers et après on fait c'est
d'autre chose puis après on a eu à
courir après un nom qui a qui a volé
quelque chose
mais ces personnes là il a sorti un
couteau puis finalement on l'a frappé
parce qu'il faut essayer c'est ça ils
ont dit plusieurs fois arrêté j'étais
ton couteau puis la personne il voulait
pas faire ça alors finalement ils ont dû
utiliser la force mais et sa journée
lancée dès la journée et de l'angle
louis sont préparés pour ça oui il faut
que soient préparées pour ça mais quand
même c'est des êtres humains qui me qui
vivait ça tous les jours ça rien bien
sûr je vais vous proposer notre question
entame cette semaine on l'a proposé à
nos internautes sur facebook sur la
plateforme facebook savait que nous on y
re transmission youtube facebook et
ainsi et en même temps pour le moment il
n'y a que la question sur facebook
peut-être qu'un jour on prend en compte
avant tout serait aventureux
mais pour sur facebook ça donne deux
résultats cette semaine deux personnes
qui ont répondu qu'ils y sent qu'il ya
de la voit ici
alors d'accord pas le maquis poète
chante alors ce crime stevens aux etats
unis c'est bien ça c'est bien je vis
dans l'appel grandes villes de new york
et je suis un blanc et non un noir et
ben oui un même comblant je ne voudrais
pas me plaindre d'un policier parce
qu'ils ont beaucoup d'amis et beaucoup
de ressources pour se défendre d'un
petit citoyen quand je me fais dire de
marcher ici et pas là alors j'écoute et
j'obéis car ils sont très facilement
irrité dans une grosse ville ou leur j
ai facilement en danger là on vous
montre la photo la vidéo est ce que vous
avez eu les petits coeurs n'avait pas eu
les peace cup ça va passer participantes
inaperçu pourquoi on voit willy petits
coeurs sur cette vidéo qui présente
notre question facebook cette semaine
c'est beau un mélange avec des policiers
les petits coeurs j'ai pas trop compris
maintenant vous cliquez sur la réponse
de madame françoise de perdus en france
elle conclut son écrit sa lettre en
disant gros bisous et avec le gros
bisous vous cliquez il ya les petits
coqs
moi je suis pas fan facebook trouve ça
fantastique c'est quand même sympathique
c'est comme ça que ça fonctionne sur
facebook on devrait y est les plus chers
oui vous n'y êtes pas vous oui
évidemment ses facettes fonctionne avec
mes enfants quand même ce cas
[Musique]
écoutez c'est une femme formidable
françoise de perdus en france à nous
écrit peut-être une fois par mois ou
même moins coup ça vous voulez lire la
réponse paraît quand même que monsieur
steven siemens a fait plusieurs fois
qu'il nous fallait qu'ils nous envoient
des mails répondu rossi s'étendent aux
habitudes alors bon je suis avec mon
mari de la génération dont les parents
ont participé aux révoltes des étudiants
vers la fin des années 60 en france
comme enfin nous avons observé nos
parents qui méprisait les gendarmes et
il disait souvent sales cochon et cetera
quand il les voyait mois les flics ne me
font pas peur je les respecte mais je ne
leur fais pas confiance
beaucoup de force dans des petites têtes
pas toujours bien aimé d'allumer ou
disons le et du quai plutôt que de m'en
plaindre je préférerais passer mon
chemin
gros bisous écoutez on est prêt pour la
fin de l'émission nous allons terminer
de belle façon en accordant un million
de dollars à l'un d'entre vous moi oui
pourquoi pas alors je rappelle les
scores pour le moment 0
oui 10,50 chanteuse de pagani la semaine
la semaine dernière j'étais pas voilà
donc gagner d'un coup un parce que ça
vaut 50 points et savions qu'on peut
renverser ben le 52 madame ici là vous
pourriez a égalé le 52 mada mais
l'habitude des victoires il se pourrait
que je suis mais je me rappelle vous
avez déjà gagné vous êtes fan c'est vrai
on est là pour la finale
50 points combien coûte à chaque
canadien les policiers sous forme de
taxes municipales provinciales et
fédérales comme ça nous coûte chaque
année par tête d'habitant rend à peu
près plus que plus que l'art est moins
que et moins que 200 milles
je peux pas vous donner des réponses
vraiment faites jouer votre imagination
ok entre 0 et 5 milles à vous payer au
moins cinq une heure de taxes tout va
aux policiers
[Musique]
alors à l'iss ban et 115 $ 75 $ pas cher
paloma c'est déjà décidé mais très bien
je me sens police s'élève tout la force
c'est-à-dire le militaire était tout ça
explique militaires les 69 28 ans né
comprend pas là tant par les soixante
sept mille policiers
c'est 350 350 dollars fabien et paloma
deux cents 200 dollars alors vous me
donnez au coeur ce la bonne réponse et 3
synthèse de la semaine
ici c'est magnifique
alors je vais vous offrir un bâton de
policiers j'en ai pas de taton de
policiers mais je ne veux pas non plus
personne ne veut de bâton de policiers
que vous avez déjà vu une arrestation
vous centre-ville à montréal magic a vu
ça où on met le le passé le futur
patients à terre c'est sûr que c'est
écouter la semaine prochaine je ne sais
pas on va parler de quelque chose de
très réjouissant
j'en suis sûr parce que je sens que la
sève du printemps commence à monter
parmi nous je n'en avoir une énorme
tempête de neige dimanche et lundi sur
une partie de l'est du pays
donc ce sera notre des revenus en baisse
à la fin il a amassé parce que ça va
fondre c'est comme ça que ça fonctionne
alors merci beaucoup chantal pour cette
semaine c'est moi qui vous remercie pour
l'invitation s'était fait une très bonne
participation à l'émission aujourd'hui
n'est pas question dans le martinez
merci à vous vous serez assez sur la
semaine prochaine à moins d'une maladie
et voilà et puis même si marc
marie-claude
il n'y a pas eu de problème technique va
bien très bien
et puis le nardo population maintenant à
les y couper le son et l'image
profitez-en
ce serait très responsable